GRAHAM WHO DIED LAST WEEK AT THE
AGE OF 99.
HE IS LYING IN HONOR FOR TWO
DAYS IN THE BUILDING BEHIND ME.
THE PRESIDENT MET WITH A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF LAWMAKERS OF
THE LATERAL SEEKING SOLUTIONS TO
WHAT SOME CONSIDER AN EPIDEMIC
OF GUN VIOLENCE IN SCHOOLS AND
PUBLIC PLACES.
LIVELY DISCUSSION IN THE CABINET
ROOM CARRY LIVE.
BOTH PARTIES.
WE WELCOME BACK CHIEF
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS.
THIS WAS HIS ORIGINAL STORY
TODAY.
OFTEN, HE GETS PUT ON OTHER
STORIES AS THEY BREAK.
GOOD EVENING.
>> IT HAPPENS FROM TIME TO TIME.
THIS WAS THE FINAL FOUR
LISTENING SESSIONS THE PRESIDENT
WAS HOLDING IN THE WAKE OF THE
SHOOTING AT THE MARJORY STONEMAN
DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL IN PARKLAND,
FLORIDA, .
SPIRITED SESSION WITH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS AIRING
THEIR IDEAS.
THE PRESIDENT TOMORROW SET TO
LAY OUT HIS ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSALS FOR IMPROVING SCHOOL
SAFETY.
IT WAS ANOTHER TV MOMENT TODAY.
THE WHITE HOUSE CANCELING THE
DAILY BRIEFING, TURNING THE
CAMERAS ON PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CONGRESSIONAL MEETING ON SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS AND GUN SAFETY.
>> WE HAVE TO ACT.
WE CAN'T WAIT AND PLAY GAMES.
NOTHING GETS DONE.
>> IS THE PRESIDENT WAS
CONVENING HIS MEETING, WORD
SPREAD THAT THE DICK'S SPORTING
GOODS CHAIN WHERE THE PARKLAND
SHOOTER ONCE BOUGHT A SHOTGUN
WOULD STOP SELLING ASSAULT
RIFLES.
>> THE SYSTEMS IN PLACE AREN'T
EFFECTIVE ENOUGH TO KEEP US FROM
SELLING SOMEONE A GUN LIKE THAT.
WE HAVE DECIDED WE ARE NOT GOING
TO SELL THE ASSAULT RIFLES
ANYMORE.
>> TOMORROW THE WHITE HOUSE WILL
UNVEIL A PACKAGE OF POLICY
PROPOSALS TO IMPROVE GUN SAFETY
AND STOP SCHOOL SHOOTINGS.
THE PRESIDENT WILL REITERATE HIS
SUPPORT FOR THE STOP SCHOOL
VIOLENCE ACT AND THE JOHN
CORNYN-MURPHY BILL.
>> NONE OF US WANT TO LOOK THESE
FAMILIES IN THE FACE IN THE WAKE
OF ANOTHER MASS SHOOTING IS THAT
WE FAILED TO DO EVERYTHING
WITHIN OUR POWER.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, IT IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BE YOU THAT BRINGS THE
REPUBLICANS TO THE TABLE BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW THE GUN LOBBY WOULD
STOP IT IN ITS TRACKS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL ASK
CONGRESS TO RAISE THE MINIMUM
AGE TO BUY ARRIVAL FROM 18 TO
21.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO DECIDE.
THE PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM ARE
GOING TO DECIDE.
I WOULD GIVE SERIOUS THOUGHT TO
IT.
I CAN SAY THAT THE NRA IS
OPPOSED.
>> THE PRESIDENT CHIDED SOME
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES, INCLUDING
PAT TOOMEY FOR BEING AFRAID OF
THE NRA.
TOMORROW THE PRESIDENT WILL ALSO
ANNOUNCE A SERIES OF
ADMINISTERED OF ACTIONS TO
EXPAND A DHS TEST PROGRAM TO
STOP SCHOOL VIOLENCE.
FIX THE FBI TIPSTER PROGRAM,
ENCOURAGE STATES TO ADOPT
EXTREME RISK PROTECTION ORDERS
TO WEAPONS COULD BE TAKEN AWAY
FROM PEOPLE WHO THREATEN TO HARM
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS, AND
ENCOURAGE ARMING SCHOOL FACULTY
AND STAFF THROUGH FEDERAL GRANTS
OR TRAINING.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WILL
ELIMINATE SO-CALLED BUMP STOCKS
WITH HIS EXECUTIVE PEN.
HE WARNED STEVE SCALISE DID NOT
ATTACH CONCEALED CARRY.
>> IF YOU ARE GOING TO PUT THAT
IN THE BILL, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT A WHOLE NEW BALL GAME.
I AM WITH YOU, BUT LET IT BE A
SEPARATE BILL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION ON HIS
MIND, TAKING HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO THE WOODSHED
AFTER JEFF SESSIONS SAID HE
WOULD ASK THE DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL TO LOOK INTO
THE FISA ABUSES ALLEGED IN THE
MEMO.
IN A TWEET, THE PRESIDENT
"WHY IS A.G. JEFF SESSIONS
ASKING THE INSPECTOR GENERAL TO
INVESTIGATE POTENTIALLY MASSIVE
FISA ABUSE.
WILL TAKE FOREVER, HAS NO
PROSECUTORIAL POWER AND ALREADY
LATE WITH REPORTS ON COMEY ETC.
ISN'T THE I.G. AN OBAMA GUY?
WHY NOT USE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
LAWYERS?
DISGRACEFUL!"
THE PRESIDENT GOT SOME BACKUP
FROM THE REVEREND JERRY
FALWELL JR. WHO TWEETED THAT
SESSIONS COULD BE JUST A COWARD.
SESSIONS, WHO WAS OFTEN STAYED
SILENT UNDER SCORCHING CRITICISM
FROM HIS BOSS, DECIDED THIS ONE
DEMANDED A RESPONSE.
ANY STATEMENT SAYING:
"WE HAVE INITIATED THE
APPROPRIATE PROCESS THAT WILL
ENSURE COMPLAINTS AGAINST THIS
DEPARTMENT WILL BE FULLY AND
FAIRLY ACTED UPON IF NECESSARY.
AS LONG AS I AM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, I WILL CONTINUE TO
DISCHARGE MY DUTIES WITH
INTEGRITY AND HONOR."
SESSIONS FOUND SUPPORT FROM TREY
GOWDY.
SAYING MICHAEL HOROWITZ "HAS
BEEN FAIR, FACT CENTRIC AND A
PROPERLY CONFIDENTIAL WITH HIS
WORK.
I HAVE COMPLETE CONFIDENCE IN
HIM."
YESTERDAY THE PRESS SECRETARY
SARAH HUCKABEE SANDERS SEEMED TO
INDICATE THE PRESIDENT WAS
PLEASED THAT SESSIONS HAD
ANNOUNCED HE WAS GOING TO
INVESTIGATE POSSIBLE FISA
ABUSES.
CLEARLY THIS WAS NOT THE TYPE OF
INVESTIGATION THAT THE PRESIDENT
WAS LOOKING FOR AND HAS AGAIN
RAISED QUESTIONS AS TO HOW MUCH
LONGER SESSIONS WILL TAKE THIS
VERY PUBLIC CRITICISM FROM THE
PRESIDENT BEFORE HE DECIDES HE